the symbol today is eta which is a
symbol for a random force so this is a
greek eater which is a strange symbol
with a vector over the top
a random force
is one that acts this way or that way
and as the time changes it goes in one
direction then another then another and
it seems to go in all directions of the
compass one after the other very quickly
the random force appears
or first appeared
to a roman person who saw dust particles
jittering about in the air when the
sunlight came into this dusty room and
you can see the particles jittering
about but it was first noticed
scientifically by robert brown who was a
botanist who saw that if you got pollen
molecules and you took the pollen out
and sprinkled it on the surface of water
and studied it
under a microscope you would see the
pollen molecules jittering about on the
surface of the liquid on the water and
he thought that this showed that pollen
was alive in some set moving all the
time jittering everywhere so he then
tested this idea by putting grains of
sand on the surface or dust or any other
particles he could find and he found
that inert particles such as a bit of
sand ground up would also jitter around
and this phenomenon is known as brownian
motion after robert brown who discovered
it and it laid hidden away in the
literature until it was resurrected in
1905
by albert einstein in his year of
miracles where he did the most amazing
work of his career he gave an
explanation of brown emotion in terms of
a random force which is moving this
particle backwards and forwards in a
tissue motion in fact the jittery motion
shows according to newton's laws the
force is the mass times the acceleration
it was accelerating every which way and
as a result
there must experimentally be a random
force
so i'm going to show you a demonstration
of this but i'm not going to use water
with grains of pollen on it i'm going to
do it using grains of
bronze which makes up the liquid so you
can actually see the motion of the
grains around bashing things and i'll
put
a grain of pollen on the top which will
actually be a polystyrene little thing
so
what i have here is
these are the grains of bronze
and this is the polystyrene blob and if
i put this into oscillation it jiggles
about if i put the grain on the top it
goes in a random motion a jittery motion
and moves to the side
if i do it again
put it in the middle
i can't get it exactly in the middle so
it's not exactly the same and now maybe
it'll go another way
and it does
and each time you do it you might get a
completely different path
down at the very small level are you
focusing on this brady a very small
level there are little grains coming in
if i pick one up i can't and it baffs
into the side then this will jitter that
way another one will come and jitter it
and ping it that way so it's as though
you're playing
you're on a billiard table and all these
balls are whizzing around in all sorts
of directions you put a balloon in the
middle and these balls are bashing
around in all sorts of directions and
sometimes it's kicked one way sometimes
it's kicked another way so this is the
idea that there are little molecules in
here in the water that are acting in
this way and some of them are hitting
one side of the balloon another time as
hitting the other side
and that's causing this jittery motion
which is why robert brown thought that
this this thing was alive so you do this
lots and lots of times and you'll
suddenly get the view that you can work
out what's going on using newton's laws
of motion and that's what einstein did
he worked out from this that you could
measure the diffusion of this pollen
grain on the surface and measure the
diffusion constant
but there's something else if this is
moving through this liquid
against all these pollen grains which
are moving there's a frictional force as
well and if you measured that frictional
force of a grain moving in a fluid
which is known from stokes's formula you
could work out this frictional force as
well and from the two
you could measure the kinetic energy of
the particle
so what you're getting in effect is the
kinetic energy which is the amount of
agitation it has and you can relate that
to the temperature of this liquid the
absolute temperature and that's what
einstein discovered that you could
combine newtonian mechanics with this
random force to thermodynamics with
gases and liquids having a temperature
an absolute temperature and this
connection
he predicted and perrin went away oh i
think it's pereira went away and did the
experiments and measured all of this and
proved it was correct
for which peridon got the nobel prize
einstein didn't
the randomness comes because these
particles come and hit it on each side
seemingly at random of course
newton's law says you can work all this
out but you can never work it out
precisely so you can't really predict
how this is going to hit and which side
it's going to hit and how big a force
it's going to be so that's why we treat
it as random
of course you might believe it's
deterministic and my friends might do
that but if if you do that then i will
invoke quantum mechanics and say we
can't actually specify everything that
precisely
so this is the random force
and its effect on physique have i
finished